le go sport
deschamps est une musique qui exprime
encore la douleur et la résilience des
noirs aux états unis une souffrance que
seuls les afro américains peuvent
comprendre des rythmes qui leur ont
permis de traverser le pays le long du
fleuve mississippi les églises des états
du sud sont un des derniers endroits où
blanc et noir ne se mêle pas la messe le
dimanche incarne encore les divisions
raciales de l'époque de la ségrégation
dans ses champs de coton que nous
traversons dans le delta du mississippi
les esclaves noirs chanter le gospel des
champs de désespoir qui ont mené aux
blues
la chanteuse nanette workman nous
accompagne sur la route du blues
elle nous amène à clarksdale ou le blues
est né s'était déclaré c'était la saga
sans qu'ils pouvaient sexe
c'était par la chanson l'aneth a grandi
dans l'état du mississipi ses racines
musicales sont ici c'est vraiment un os
dans la soupe
le la musique ici dans cette petite
ville près du fleuve mississippi vivent
encore les meilleurs bluesman james
johnson alias super chikane fabrique lui
même ses guitares avec lesquels il joue
du blues
partout dans le monde pour lui cette
musique a été un moteur de changement
pour les afro américains
ce soir-là super chikane joue au bar
grande cible
la mecque du blues propriété de l'acteur
morgan freeman et du maire de la ville
bo la quête nous sommes en plein
festival de blues à clarksdale
à une certaine époque
impossible pour un gland d'entrer dans
un bar blues à crocs des villes à
majorité noire
le maire de clarksdale a vécu la
ségrégation des années 50 et 60
aujourd'hui dit-il blancs et noirs se
côtoient un peu plus mais blanc et noir
sont toujours prisonniers d'un lourd
passé raciale or les cinq ans bobcats
n'a pris et 5 en public à ce point
toute la musique du monde ne ramènera
pas l'harmonie totale le long du
mississipi beaucoup d'eau va couler
encore sous les ponts avant que blanc et
noir ne vibrent au même diapason